you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
why tea and those who grow it are at
risk from our changing climate
a green wave or a bit of a washout we
get the view from westminster on how the
green party fared in the local elections
and we meet the devon-based company on a
mission to make
cleaning more sustainable
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
climate change could be threatening the
much-loved british cup of tea
and the livelihoods and homes of those
who grow it
extreme weather and rising temperatures
mean both the amount of land available
for growing tea
and the taste of the leaves produced are
being affected
a report from christian aid suggests
that optimal conditions for tea
production in kenya
the biggest exporter of black tea could
fall by a quarter by 2050.
so these are the top countries that
export tea to
britain and let's take a look at the
threats to the crops in some of the main
regions
well in sri lanka where they export more
than 1
200 tons of tea rising temperatures
are shrinking the areas suitable for
growing salon tea
in china longer monsoon seasons are
changing the amount of tea that can be
harvested
the quality and taste are suffering as
the plants react to different conditions
almost 10 000 tons of tea is exported to
the uk
from india and the combination of both
an increase in temperatures and
intense rainfall means ideal conditions
for pests and insects
that can ruin crops and half of all the
tea drunk in the uk
is grown in kenya now it's facing
prolonged droughts which mean the
optimum tea growing areas
could be severely affected well joining
me now from nairobi is mohammad ado
who's director of powershift africa an
energy and climate think tank
welcome to you so how great is the
threat from climate change to
tea growing there in kenya
tea which is actually a very important
commodity that is produced in kenya is
actually currently and a threat from
climate change
lots of parts of the country that grow
tea have been actually suffering some of
the worst impacts of climate change
and that way affecting the livelihoods
of the two growing population
so what does it mean then for the
farmers and also for kenya's economy
kenya is actually the third largest
produce of tea and the world's biggest
exporter
accounting for nearly 22 percent of the
world
exports our tea is vital to our economy
approximately 10 percent of our
population depend on tea for their
livelihood
t is not only a top employer but also a
top contributor to kenya's expert anime
you know 40 of our tea is grown in large
scale
plantations that employs some hundred
thousand workers
while the rest is actually grown by over
six hundred thousand small-scale
farmers additionally tea contributes to
four percent of our kenyans of our gdp
while
t exports contribute 26 percent of
kenya's
export annual and so if tea gets
affected
that means that a good part of the
population that depends on tea growing
are actually going to be affected and so
is our economy
and in the uk and ireland we drink more
tea per person than any other country
around the world i hear so could the uk
do more would you like the uk to do more
uk is actually the creator of the
industrial revolution
together with the rest of the rich world
you know they produce
far larger proportion of greenhouse
gases which cause climate change
and its people like our team farmers who
contributed the least we've imprinted
the lightest carbon footprint on the
planet
were actually suffering the most from
its impact and so
the emissions reduction plan that
countries including the uk have put on
the table
uh since paris do not deliver a safe
wall which is what we need
if we're going to be able to contain
climate change and so what we need
going into glasgow if you know into
glasgow for cop26
is for all countries to actually ramp up
the emissions reduction pledges
so that we can put the world on a safe
trajectory that is effectively going to
help
protect the tea growing population but
also all communities on the front line
mohamed thanks very much indeed thank
you let's take a look now some of the
day's other climate news and uk
retailers have cut their carbon
emissions in half since 2005.
new figures from the british retail
consortium show some of the sector's
leading companies have beaten their
environmental targets for the last year
more than 70 retailers have signed up to
the group's climate action road map
which aims to build a more sustainable
economy
[Applause]
people are being encouraged to get out
in the great outdoors to improve their
mental health
research by the mental health foundation
has shown nature has had a positive
impact on people in the uk
during the pandemic seventy percent of
adults say
being close to nature improves their
mood and almost half think it makes them
less worried or anxious
[Applause]
so david attenborough is warning world
leaders to find a solution to
environmental issues which he says
will get worse over the next few years
the broadcaster has been named the
people's advocate at the cop 26 climate
conference due to be held in glasgow in
november
sir david says it's crucial leaders work
together
to solve the climate crisis it is
crucial
that these meetings in glasgow cop
26 have success and that at last
the nations will come together to solve
the crippling problems that the world
the globe now faces the green party
says it's had the best local election
results in the party's history
in england they gained 88 councillors
and now hold a total
of 151 english council seats
in the scottish parliament election the
scottish greens gained
two seats and in london's mayoral
election the green party candidate sean
berry came in third
receiving just under 200 000 first
preference votes that's double
the party's total in 2012. well our
chief political correspondent john craig
joins me now and john to what extent is
this improvement in the green party's
fortunes
mark do we think an increased concern in
the public about green issues
green issues are much bigger than they
were a few years back
and uh clearly the green party has
benefited from
first of all concern about environmental
issues climate change
the prime minister of course is hosting
a big summit later this year
he's under pressure from john kerry from
the united states to
announce some really big targets and the
political parties here in the uk
are obviously uh burnishing their their
green credentials and
it's paying off for the green party
today uh jonathan
bartley told sky news we're staking the
claim
to become england's third party and as
you've said anna
they overtook the lib dems in the
contest for london mayor
in fact sean berry polled almost twice
the number
of uh votes as the liberal democrats
candidate in london
they did very well in bristol too they
won
24 seats up from 11.
laborer also on 24 and so the
labour mayor marvin reese is under
pressure now to appoint some green
councillors
to his cabinet now we often speak about
the role that countries have in tackling
the climate crisis but that's not the
whole story
cities regions investors and businesses
are all going to be crucial to reducing
emissions
and keeping global warming below 1.5
degrees
well nigel topping is the uk's high
level climate action champion for cop26
and is working to drive action from
these sectors
i spoke to him earlier and started by
asking what success looks like
for the cop26 summit in november
well i think three things one the the
negotiations the actual
complex technical negotiations to
finalize the paris rule book
need to be completed successfully as
proof that the multilateral system's
still working
then then all the countries of the world
need to meet the promise of paris
and come with bigger commitments we've
seen a lot of that but um
importantly those include some more
commitments on finance from the global
north
to global south and then finally and
that's the bit where my role
comes in a huge momentum in the real
economy that
businesses cities investors and all of
us are
driving towards the zero carbon economy
of the future
the eu's climate commissioner has
recently said that society
needs to undergo a tectonic shift if
we're going to go green so how do you
persuade people
to engage with that when what they hear
about cop is those
targets that you talk about it's about
percentages and numbers how do you get
people on board
when that's the narrative if you're
talking to a ceo
it's about um the the competitiveness
you know society's decided we're going
to zero and we have to harvest missions
in the next
10 years if you're not playing your part
in that you're
going to lose the battle for talent
because people won't want to come to
work for you and you're going to lose
the battle
for market share and if you're an
individual then there are individual
things you can do by
using your vote wisely and uh by by
making
purchase decisions yourself to buy
things which are zero carbon or
massively reduced carbon than um than in
the past so it depends who you are but
there's something for everybody to do
and how does that relate to government
you say no medals for setting targets
the government set very ambitious
targets world leading targets
78 reduction in emissions by 2035 but
are the policies there to achieve that
what's your view
we're seeing some really strong targets
you know phasing out of coal by 2024
phasing out combustion engines
by 2013 massive ramp up in renewable
energy
um but every country where you're seeing
these bold targets now
there's a lag between the headline
target and then the policies
coming through i think the thing that
you can see is the way the private
sector is reacting now they know that
those policies
if they're not already there they're
coming very soon that's why we had
160 firms with 70 trillion dollars
of assets join the glasgow finance
alliance for net zero they've realized
that
policy and public requirements are only
going in one direction that's direction
of the science
it's estimated that around 468 million
spray bottles from cleaning products
will be thrown away in the uk
every year many of these are difficult
to recycle because of the different
materials used in the nozzles and pumps
in today's climate diaries we hear from
emma who founded the company elm kind
with her partner alex
they found a way of using refillable
aluminium bottles for their cleaning
products to try to address the problem
of plastic pollution
[Applause]
[Music]
a few years ago my partner alex and i
realized that there was a huge issue
with the way cleaning products were
being sold
[Music]
the family could only be bought in
plastic bottles and once used these
cheap bottles would inevitably break and
end up in landfill
or worse in our oceans affecting our
seas and our wildlife
[Music]
but over 400 million of plastic spray
bottles
solely from cleaning products alone were
being thrown away every year in the uk
so in august 2019 we launched elm kind
we're a plant-based eco-friendly yet
effective alternative to home cleaning
product
since launching we've so far saved over
10 000
plastic spray bottles from ending up in
landfill
as we're still seeing haunting images of
animals being washed up with
microplastics in their stomachs
it's clear that a lot more still is to
be done
and that's all from us for today on
tomorrow's show we're talking
reforestation instead of
deforestation and finding out how many
trees have been planted
since the millennium that's at the same
time tomorrow here on sky news
see you then
[Music]
you